NINICOLE DESGAGNÉS, porte-parole
dudu comité citoyen ARET
- - On est beaucoup portés
papar de la colère, puis un peu
dede l'indignation, parce qu'on
esest parents, ou dans mon cas,
grgrands-parents d'enfants qui
hahabitent soit le quartier
ouou autour et on ne savait pas.
pupuis autour de la table,
dadans notre comité ARET,
ilil y a plein de monde qui état
plplacé pour connaître ces
ininformations en théorie :
pépédiatres, néonat' autour
dede la table, moi, j'étais
gegestionnaire dans le réseau
dede la santé. La colère, elle t
llà, parce qu'on se disait :
CÇa n'a pas de bon sens qu'on
n'n'ait pas su pour l'arsenic.
OnOn savait qu'il y avait du
plplomb, puis qu'il y a avait
dede la réhabilitation de sol.
OnOn pensait que c'était limité
dadans le quartier, c'était déjà
unun peu inquiétant, mais on ne
s's'attendait pas à ce qu'il y t
dedes rejets aussi importants.
A À Rouyn-Noranda, la populatin
etet les médecins se mobilisent.
PrPrès de la fonderie Horne,
leles quantités d'arsenic
dédépassent largement la norme
pepermise au Québec.
UnUne cinquantaine de médecins e
lala région lancent un ultimatum
auau premier ministre François
LeLegault pour que la santé
dede la population passe avant
totous les autres intérêts.
LeLe Collège des médecins appuie
cecette demande. J'en parlerai
dadans un instant avec la députe
dede Rouyn-Noranda-Témiscamingu.
MaMais d'abord avec l'initiatrie
dede cette lettre, la Dre Marie-
PiPier Lemieux, médecin de famie
auau GMF-U de Rouyn-Noranda.
DrDre Lemieux, bonsoir.
- - Bonsoir.
- - Vous et vos collègues êtes
vivisiblement inquiets pour la
sasanté de la population à Rouy-
NoNoranda. Est-ce que dans votre
prpratique même vous voyez
dedes effets de l'arsenic?
- - En fait, comme je l'ai
exexpliqué à certains de vos
cocollègues journalistes un peu
plplus tôt, l'enjeu, c'est que
dadans une population comme cele
ququ'on peut suivre comme médecn
dede famille comme groupent de
mémédecins, c'est impossible
d'd'avoir un effet de ce genre e
sisituation parce que c'est une
trtrop petite population. Ça nos
prprend vraiment des chiffres qi
nonous permet d'avoir une
popopulation plus globale, un pu
cocomme ce que la santé publique
nonous a offert comme étude dans
leles dernières semaines. C'est
vrvraiment ce genre d'étude qui
pepeut nous permettre d'avoir ue
ididée plus générale de cece que
papasse et de mieux comprendre
vrvraiment les impacts que ça pt
avavoir sur la santé parce qu'à
l'l'échelle d'une plus petite
popopulation, on n'est pas capae
dede savoir.
- - Donc ce n'est pas parce que
vovous constatez, mais c'est pae
quque vous pensez que les
émémissions... sachant que les
émémissions dépassent largement
leles normes, c'est un fait con,
vovous redoutez des effets poura
sasanté de la population?
- - On fait plus que les redout,
onon le sait parce que dans le
fofond, les données de la santé
pupublique nous démontrent qu'iy
a a plus d'un cancer des poumons
auau Noranda que dans le reste e
lala province, il y a plus de
mamaladies Bonnaire chronique.
CoComme vous l'avez mentionné,
acaccolé au fait qu'on ce qu'ily
a a de nombreux contaminants das
l'l'air qui dépasse largement ls
nonormes établies, deux et deux
fofont quatre.
- - Le lien de cause à effet ene
leles émissions hors normes de a
fofonderie et ses problèmes de
sasanté, pour vous, les liens de
cacause à effet même s'il n'est
papas encore établi
scscientifiquement, il vous
apapparaît évident? Soit on ne
pepeut pas se permettre d'attene
ququ'un lien de causalité Françs
ététablie. Dans une population
auaussi petite, ce sera toujours
didifficile parce que les chiffs
nene seront jamais suffisamment
élélevés pour que la significatn
ststatistique soit suffisant. Dc
ilil faut se contenter entre
guguillemets des ces éléments
ququ'on a déjà mais qui sont
lalargement suffisants à notre
avavis pour sonner l'alarme.
- - Cela dit, quand même, pourqi
cecette lettre ouverte maintenat
prprécisément? Parce que les
dodonnées dont vous parlez, il a
dedes études depuis 2019. La
dédéputée qu'on va interviewer
totout à l'heure ça va depuis
202019. Pourquoi vous signez ça
auaujourd'hui comme médecin?
- - C'est sûr que la situation t
prpréoccupante depuis 2019 et en
202019, ce qu'on nommait, c'état
l'l'imprégnation des personnes u
enen tout cas les gens avaient e
ququantité d'arsenic dans les
ononglets qui étaient mesurés
susupérieurs à la moyenne. Ce
ququ'on se demandait et c'est
popourquoi on avait pas de
dodonnées, c'est l'impact sur la
sasanté. C'était ça que les gens
nonous reprochaient. Est-ce quea
fafaisait vraiment quelque chose
avavoir des taux plus élevés
d'd'arsenic et des métaux lourds
dadans les onglets? Je dirais qe
cece qui a changé dans les
dedernières semaines, ce sont ls
dodonnées que la santé publique
nonous a fournies à l'effet que
ououi, clairement, il y a plus e
mamaladies, il y a une diminutin
dede la longévité. C'est un
prproblème. Clairement, on a
ququelque chose de concret à se
memettre sous la dent et je pene
quque les gens sont plus à l'aie
dede nommer clairement que ça ne
fafait pas de sens.
- - Ce que vous demandez à
MoMonsieur Legault, c'est de
pepermettre à la fonderie de
n'n'émettre que ce qui est perms
aiailleurs dans la province. Les
mmêmes normes devraient
s's'appliquer. Ce serait énorme
cocomme réduction. Je pense
ququ'elle est à moins de 90 ng r
mmètre cube. Il faudrait la
raramener à 3 ng par mètre cube.
- - Exactement. En fait, il n'ya
papas de raison que la populatin
dede Rouyn-Noranda n'est pas acs
àà la même qualité d'air que le
rereste du Québec. C'est ça le
memessage essentiel que nous on
veveut passer. C'est : on a le
drdroit à la même qualité d'air
ququ'ailleurs. Si la norme est e
3 3 ng, ça devrait être la mêmeu
NoNoranda d'autant plus qu'on a
cocommencé à montrer des effets
susur la santé de la population.
- - Peut-être que ça a été
acacceptable longtemps encore ds
ememplois créés par la fonderie.
CÇa représente 600 emplois. Peu-
êêtre même que parmi vos
papatients, il y a des gens qui
trtravaillent là. Est-ce que
cecelle-ci explique cela peut-
êêtre?
- - Trèès certainement ça a eu n
imimpact parce que dans une
hihistoire de la ville, la
fofonderie a toujours été très
prprésente et on comprend ça.
QuQuand on regarde l'historique
auaussi des luttes
enenvironnementales en lien avec
lala fonderie, les médecins ont
totoujours été très prudents das
leleur prise de position parce
ququ'il y avait tout l'enjeu...s
enenjeux sociaux et de la santé,
écéconomique et tout ça. Je
pepensais présentement en 2022 à
RoRouyn-Noranda, on est plus
MeMesure de payer ce coup pour
avavoir une relance économique.
CÇa ne fait plus de sens de
cocontinuer à ce que les gens
papayent ses prix de leur santé.
- - Une dernière question très
rarapidement, le Docteur Boileau
sese rend à Rouen demain. À quoi
vovous attendez-vous de sa part?
- - Je m'attends ou du moins
j'j'espère très fortement que
DoDocteur Boileau sera d'accordt
ununira sa voix à la nôtre pour
exexiger exactement la même choe
dudu gouvernement de Monsieur
LeLegault. Ce qu'on demande, c't
rerevenir à la norme et j'espère
quque Monsieur Boileau sera
d'd'accord avec nous.
- - Docteur Lemieux, merci
bebeaucoup, au revoir.
J Je poursuis maintenant
avavec Émilise Lessard-Therrien,
dédéputée solidaire de Rouyn-
NoNoranda-Témiscamingue.
LeLes médecins, on vient de
l'l'entendre, valider les normes
d'd'émission d'arsenic soient ls
mmêmes Arouet Noranda, les mêmes
ququ'ailleurs au Québec. Est-ce
quque la réponse du cabinet du
prpremier ministre qui a répondu
auaujourd'hui par texte en disat
ququ'on y travaillait, on étaitn
trtrain de négocier avec la
fofonderie, qu'on les avait
réréduites déjà considérablemen,
mamais qu'elles étaient encore
trtrop élevées, est-ce que vous
avavez le sentiment qu'on va fir
papar arriver aux mêmes normes
ququ'ailleurs?
- - Si on n'y arrive, c'est pare
ququ'il y aura eu une mobilisatn
hihistorique du côté de roi
NoNoranda et cette mobilisation
esest en train de prendre
fefermement naissance et de
prprendre de l'ampleur. Réduire
leles émissions
d'd'arsenic, les discours de la
CACAQ depuis le jour un, depuis
202019 au on en parle. C'est
totoujours ce qu'ils ont dit.
MaMaintenant, qu'est-ce qu'ils t
fafait pour que ça se passe
réréellement? Est-ce qu'ils ont
rerehaussé les exigences?
PaParce que la fonderie, elle va
jojouer dans le... dans les lims
dudu carré de sable qui va lui
dodonner le gouvernement du Quéc
etet en ce moment, le gouvernemt
lului donne 33 fois la norme du
QuQuébec. C'est ça qui n'est pas
acacceptable. Ils sont en traine
rerenégocier la prochaine ciblet
DoDocteur Lemieux l'a bien dit,a
prprochaine cible n'a pas d'aute
chchoix que d'être la norme
ququébécoise.
JeJe pense qu'à l'heure actuell,
lala CAQ a totalement perdu la
coconfiance des gens de rois
NoNoranda qui ont l'impression e
leles impératifs économiques
prpriment sur leur propre santét
sisi la CAQ veut regagner la
coconfiance des gens de roi
NoNoranda, elle n'aura pas le
chchoix d'exiger le 3 ng.
- - Est-ce que vous diriez que s
gogouvernements qui ont succédé
onont accordé ce passe-droit?
- - La fonderie Horne, comme ele
esest en activité depuis la fin
dedes années 20, elle a comme un
drdroit acquis de polluer. Le nm
scscientifique pour ça, ce sont
leles attestations
d'd'assainissement. Il y a eu du
lalaxisme pendant des décennies.
ElElle a eu droit d'émettre 67
fofois la norme du Québec pendat
1515 ans. Il y a eu des longs
momoments où ces attestations
dedevaient être renouvelées et l
n'n'y avait rien qui se passait.
C'C'est l'héritage du gouvernemt
lilibéral. C'est l'héritage du
gogouvernement péquiste. Et là,
c'c'est l'héritage de la coalitn
avavenir Québec. Là où la donne
chchange, c'est que maintenant,n
alallait donner. Et donc moi, je
m'm'attends à ce qu'il y ait un
gegeste ambitieux qui soit posé.
- - Du point de vue de la
fofonderie, est-ce que c'est
fafacile de faire ça? On voit
ququ'elle a négocié une diminutn
dede l'appétit. Est-ce que c'est
fafacile techniquement parlant
popour une fonderie comme la
fofonderie Horne qui est une
grgrosse fonderie de réduire ses
émémissions, de passer de 90 ng
dede passer de 90 ng par mètre
mmètre cube? Souhaite en fait, e
pepense que ce qui n'est pas
fafacile, c'est de mettre la man
dadans sa poche émettre les sous
quque pour atteindre les moyens
tetechnologiques pour y arriver.
OnOn parle de contrôler ça prend
dedes poussières, des émanations
dedes poussières, des émanatio s
fafamilles ns fugitives, donc
C'C'est quand les camions
papassaient et autres.
LaLa multinationale sociale dans
leles poches de ses actionnaire4
mimilliards de dollars en févrir
dedernier. La question, c'est de
sasavoir combien ça va coûter.
- - Le gouvernement est prêt à
aiaider financièrement
l'l'entreprise pour qu'elle mete
seses installations à niveau. E-
cece qu'on devrait payer pour ç?
- - Moi, je pense que la répons,
c'c'est non. Glencore a les moys
d'd'investir dans les mesures
enenvironnementales pour prévenr
lala santé de la population de i
NoNoranda. Le gouvernement du
QuQuébec, son rôle, c'est de
lélégiférer pour restreindre le
cacarré de sable dans laquelle a
jojouer la fonderie. Ce n'est ps
dede subventionner cette
enentreprise qui nous rend mala.
OnOn paie déjà suffisamment chèe
avavec nos soins de santé, avec
neneuf santé qui est hypothéqué.
- - Reste à voir si l'entente sa